I read 72 books sorry I lied in the
title that's right in 2018
I read 72 books here in my garage and
this is all my knowledge and the other
dead means 28 year old man discovers
books is a thing if sander of the year
and I wanted to make a sort of summary
and talk about some of my favorite books
that I read this year and I also wanted
to make this book to hopefully inspire
you guys there were more people in
general to read as well the percentage
of teenagers that read for fun is at an
all-time low let's change that oh yeah
the reason why I started reading was
because I made actually a New Year's
resolution so I thought okay well maybe
this could you guys can pick the same
resolution maybe you guys have the same
problems as I had which is that I kind
of have a problem with finishing things
it sounds a bit weird but generally as
soon as things get a little difficult I
get bored and I move on to something
else and this could be for even silly
stuff like playing a video game if it
gets boring at some point I don't really
care to finish it I'll just buy a new
game or move on to something else or
whether it's a hobby project as soon as
it gets a little boring I generally
don't finish it so I I miss that feeling
them finishing something I missed that
gratifying feeling though you know even
if it wasn't the most fun okay I still
and I'm glad I went through with it I'm
still glad I I can move on to the next
thing
preachy woman incoming
and in case hasn't been preaching enough
so far I think especially with social
media as well we should literally never
has an end to it it's just something
that keeps going and going and going and
going I wanted to have that feeling so I
said by my new year's resolution was
gonna be that no matter what I do I'm
gonna finish it and I didn't have books
in mind at all it just sort of became a
coincidence that I decided okay I'll
read a book and I'm leaving if I don't
like it I don't care I'm just gonna
finishing it finish it so I started off
with reading sci-fi and to be fair I
didn't really enjoyed that much I'm
still buying I read it and I knew I
wanted to read something different next
and I really enjoyed that and it just
sort of came moved on and on and on and
Here I am later and I'm so happy I'm so
glad I made this decision one of the
major discoveries for me this year was
discovering my favorite author which I
talked a lot about on this channel which
is Yukio Mishima didn't know anything
about this author when I read him which
I think really added to the effect for
me so I almost don't want to talk about
him because discovering him as was
equally as fun almost or really added to
the experience for me I it out on
Twitter asking if there was any
recommendations for Japanese authors
because I enjoyed reading the more I
count me and I didn't really expect much
of it I thought Yukio was a female name
I thought it was a female author because
when I read the Sailor fell from grace
would see I just felt so incompletely
merged into the main character's mind
which is something I never really
experienced before with literature even
though this character this young boy
very special to say the least I I was I
was there I was into it and I felt like
I got a window into that time and period
when this was written
and that really is why I was so drawn to
his literature afterwards studying the
book learning about Yukio Mishima is
life you certainly learn more about the
meaning the symbolism and the ideas that
motivated his work which makes it even
more interesting so I think that's why
for me you commissioned had such an
impact this
and also reading more about his
non-fictional work like son steel for
example it was his way of living he he
wanted to reintroduce the samurai way of
living into Japan and a lot of his book
reflects that idea on the ship that
Japan went through during the Meiji
period shortly after the Second World
War this is sorry this is the point is
he wrote summon steel which was for a
magazine and he was an avid body lifter
weightlifter which is not your typical I
guess writer hobby because he believed
in Sun and steel which is his take on
the old and old samurai saying the
flower and the sword as oversimplifying
it but basically it was this idea that
samurais should spend just as much time
writing poetry as they spend time
practicing with their sword and Mishima
felt like Japan had forgotten about
their steel or the sword of Japan and
especially during the westernization of
Japan a lot of his work like runaway
horses his tetralogy in the temple of
dawn they all reflect this this shift it
was also obsessed with the idea of dying
young and he really dramatis eyes that
and Mishima was supposed to win the
Nobel Prize he was supposed to be one of
the first winners this sort of became an
essay I don't know why I didn't mean
sorry I just I like talking about
Mishima he was a poet because it's very
interesting he was supposed to win them
the Nobel Prize but he was kind of a
misunderstood character and still fairly
young to receive such an award so he he
got snob then he went to one of his
peers instead and I think twice even he
was supposed to win the Nobel Prize it
was sort of taken that yeah he's still
young we don't really know who he is yet
so when he gets older it will probably
get the award but four people are know
by Mishima he never made it that far
the very fact fascinating author his
life is equally as fascinating as his
work so that has been one of my favorite
things that I discovered this year just
reading his books I
loved it I read his tetralogy I read
someone who I guess more weird stuff his
short stories there's so much great work
from him that I just I feel I enjoy
every page that I read the second thing
that I really enjoyed discovering this
year which is something that I never
thought I would say which is Buddhism
that's right everybody I think a lot of
people can benefit from Buddhism not
from a religious thing fun but just I
think if you embrace Buddhism as a
philosophy there's so much to learn
especially for me I think with the ideas
around self-control and why you
shouldn't indulge in the
self-destructive behavior just is
something man I really benefited from
and it's something that I never really
was taught so I'm really glad I read
this book I picked it up on a complete
win and the Sun came out of nowhere and
I'm getting blasted like an inferno
Jesus I find it interesting cuz a lot of
its ideas on why you shouldn't indulge
in self-destructive behavior sort of
correlates to another book that I read
I've talked about before which is man's
search for meaning my bike victory
Franko who's a Holocaust survivor he
survived I think two or three
concentration camps and he made the
observation that people that you know
started smoking or the self-destructive
things on the camp's avoid the people
that had kind of given up on on in
general and these were the people that
would soon after obviously not for
everyone but would pass away because
they they lost their meaning that they
lost their their grip I guess you could
say you know Here I am privileged little
sweet boy why should I do these
self-destructive things what's the
meaning for me to do that and Frankel
says as well that you should live your
life as if you've already make made your
mistakes as if you already lived in and
made all your mistakes because that
changes your approach
life in a meaningful way and this
connects a lot to the ideas in my
opinion around reincarnation which
sounds really weird for me to say but
and it gives you a positive meaning and
outlook on life in my opinion regardless
if you embrace the religious and
spiritual aspect of it in regardless if
you believe in that or not I I think is
irrelevant or at least actually it is
relevant but it doesn't really change
anything it doesn't change the outcome I
guess you could say if you have a
meaning for something you can go through
any suffering and Buddhism treats life
as suffering this became very weird my
final point life sucks I want to tell us
a touch upon this opions which I because
I think that's something that a lot of
people like to start off reading myself
included one of the earliest books that
I read this year was brave new world
written by Aldous Huxley I love this one
especially because it's a good mixture
of comedy intentional or not I don't
know
and if how agreement gets as well how
dark it is which it really delivers this
impactful meaning behind it I don't want
to go too much into it sorry but the
main reason I'm bringing this up is
because a lot of you guys are
recommending this book to me which is
Fahrenheit 451 which is another dystopia
which depicts a future where people
won't read books they have the same idea
generally but I think these are two
great examples of this one has a great
elevator pitch this one doesn't but this
one has so much more impactful meaning
behind it this just sounds to me like
the rambling of an angry old man this is
the one that's going to get a movie
adapted to it I think lilies things is
even acting in it so it's gonna be great
daddy daddy beauty and government
controlled information versus
information in the media today I'd say
pretty identical just go on any social
media website and you'll see that
there's two sides to every story and
everyone you literally just sound like a
crying baby in an idiot which you are
Lilly sings it's so bad this book is so
terrible I think it's the perfect
example of a book that
the moral is the core center of the of
the novel which just makes it so goddamn
boring in my opinion the beauty of
fiction is when you have characters that
are interesting and the story that
really grips you in a way that the ideas
behind it isn't as transparent and they
have so much more impact in my opinion
this is so rambling so poorly written it
blows my mind that this is what it gets
recommended so don't read this one
there's so many better to still be this
out there whenever you go as well on the
top rated books on online and you see
see what's popular a lot of it is
self-help book which is fine obviously
they have a purpose and there's a lot to
learn from that as well but I would
really emphasize that reading fiction
read fiction there's really no better
way to to get the meaning behind
something in my opinion instead of get
just getting it spoon-fed to you and I
hope that more people get into reading
fiction as well and and don't just read
nonfiction because I know I have a lot
of younger guys watching me and I know
younger guys generally tend to stray
more towards nonfiction instead of
fiction but you're missing out okay did
it a skin extremely dark in here
goddamnit I think that's all I wanted to
say I couldn't probably ramble on a lot
more thank you for listening so far I
again I really hope this inspires more
of you to read as well because I had a
lot of fun this year and I also would
recommend to start small and also maybe
set a goal for yourself I think instead
of reading 50 pages and then or 300
pages and stopping it's better to just
read something small like 10 pages a day
that's better if you're consistent with
it at least then stopping and I think
you'll find that you'll get into it
quicker than you think obviously if
you're not used to reading which I
wasn't
time it's a little harder to get into
but once you do it's great it's really
fun if this video gets 5,000 likes I
will give away my favorite book of the
year which is the Cat in the Hat now
this book I'm thinking about doing the
whole series about it's got that genius